تحت وطاه ازمه ماليه واقتصاديه غير مسبوقه
يرزح اللبنانيون منذ سنوات واحد ابرز
تداعياتها تعدد اسعار صرف الدولار وانعكاس
ذلك على معيشتهم
مما لا شك فيه ان سعر صرف الدولار في
السوق الموازيه هو الاكثر تداولا وهو في
ارتفاع مستمر يليه سعره منصه صيرفه التي
انشاها المصرف المركزي ويوفر من خلالها
الدولارات للمواطنين بسعر اقل اما سعر
الصرف الرسمي المثبت منذ عقدين ونصف فقد
رفعه المصرف المركزي عشره اضعاف فما حجم
التداعيات والانعكاسات
احمد واحد ممن سينعكس قرار تعديل سعر
الصرف على احوالهم يعمل في اكثر من مجال
لتغطيه التزاماته
لاسيما تسديد 12 الف دولار كان اقترضها من
احد البنوك سدد جزءا من المبلغ بالليره
وفق سعر صرف الرسمي السابق وبات عاجزا
الان عن سداد الدفعه الشهريه التي ارتفعت
عشره اضعاف والله كنت اخذ كرد على 12 الف
وفجاه كنا عم نسكره صار على 12 على 8000
رجعوا من 8000 رجعوا عملوه على 15 الف طيب
نحنا وانجا عم نطلع اجار البيت لكن
القراره لا ينعكس على تعاملات الماليه
والتجاريه التي تعتمد سعر الدولار وفق
منصه صيرفه او سوق الموازيه لن تتاثر كذلك
الضرائب والرسوم الحكوميه التي تحتسب منذ
اشهر على قاعده 15 الف ليره لكل دولار
بالواقع التداعيات راح تكون خفيفه لسبب
بسيط اولا انه التداعيات الاساسيه تجاهيه
صارت تمت عبر الموازنه يعني نحن عم نحكي
عن الدولار الجمركي وعن الرسوم المرتبطه
بالدولار ارتفعوا مسبقا ويمهدوا تعديل سعر
الصرف وفق ما اعلن المصرف المركزي الى
تحرير سعر الدولار مستقبلا وتوحيده خطوه
يشكك الخبراء في امكانيه تحققها لافتقاد
المصرف المركزي الى الاحتياطات النقديه
بالدولار للتدخل في السوق هذا احد
الاجراءات المسبقه يلي
تضمنها الاتفاق بين لبنان وصندوق النقد
الدولي بنيسان الماضي
وكان اخر بند بين هالبنود التسعه يلي
المفروض يطبق لبنان قبل ما يوقع صندوق
النقد على قرض 3 مليارات دولار لكن البنود
الاخرى لم تطبق بعد وفي طليعتها الاصلاحات
الماليه والتشريعات البرلمانيه التي يجب
ان تواكبها بسبب الازمه السياسيه في لبنان
وتعذر تنفيذ خطه الانقاذ التي اقرتها
الحكومه جوني طونيوس الجزيره بيروت